mais d'abord donc la dynamique Le Pen
dans les derniers sondages avec Cécile
Sixou
d'après les sondages le 10 avril
prochain 21% des Français ont
l'intention de mettre dans l'urne un
bulletin de vote Marine Le Pen en cette
fin de campagne la candidatérienne qui
stagnait jusqu'à présent entre 17 et 18%
opèrent une remontée le fruit selon ce
politologue d'une campagne bien gérée
par la candidate
c'est pas agité finalement elle a été
plutôt patient dans son premier temps de
campagne où elle avait vu distancer
notamment par Éric Zemmour et puis à la
finalement attendu dans cette deuxième
tente campagne où il y a eu finalement
la lueur de la crise
ukrainienne et de la guerre en Ukraine
l'émergence évidemment d’enjeux sociaux
extrêmement importante à que le pouvoir
d'achat la stratégie de faire campagne
sur le pouvoir d'achat plutôt que sur
l'immigration comme Eric Zemmour s'est
avéré payante face à elle Emmanuel
Macron crédité de 28% des intentions de
vote pour le premier tour ne progresse
plus le président candidat à beau rester
en tête en cas de duel avec la candidat
RN au second tour il ne serait selon un
sondage et Lab plus qu'à 5 points
d'écart avec pour lui 52,5% d'intention
et pour elle 47,5
courbes qui se rapproche entre Emmanuel
Macron et Marine Le Pen déjà c'est un
report de voix beaucoup plus favorable
pour Marine Le Pen entre le premier et
le second tour de l'électorat Zemmour ou
une certaine partie de l'électorat aussi
Mélenchon qui serait prêt à se reporter
alors évidemment pas majoritairement sur
un vote Marine Le Pen et ces deux
reports de voix qui lui sont beaucoup
plus favorables lui permettent
aujourd'hui effectivement d'augmenter
son score de de second tour
une inconnue qui pourrait changer la
donne l'abstention
donc cette question jusqu'où montera
Marine Le Pen et on en débat avec mes
invités claire Chartier bonsoir c'est
journaliste essayiste
Erwan Le Coeur bonsoir vous êtes
politologues sociologue au laboratoire
pacte j'accueille également
Pierre-Adrien Bartoli bonsoir le
directeur des études politiques à
l'institut Harris Interactive et
Laetitia Copa éditorialiste politique
bonsoir Laetitia je commence avec vous
pierre Adrien et votre dernier
sondage pour challenge avec un Emmanuel
Macron à on va voir vraiment les 12
candidats à 28 et demi en légère baisse
Marine Le Pen qui progresse à 21%
ensuite on a Jean-Luc Mélenchon 15% et
puis ensuite
Eric Zemmour Valérie Pécresse Yannick
Jadot Fabien Roussel et on classe
maintenant à Hidalgo dans je mets des
guillemets les petits candidats parce
qu'elle est à 2% de et demi pour cent
Nicolas dupontaignan à deux Jean lassala
2 Philippe poutouadeux et Nathalie
Arthaud à 0,5 voilà pour le constat le
dernier concert mais nous c'est vrai
qu'on se sélectionne toujours en
cherchant à analyser les dynamiques de
campagne et c'est et c'est ma première
question la réponse on la trouve dans
vos sondages ou dans d'autres elle est
clairement positive pour Marine Le Pen
depuis plusieurs plusieurs sondages oui
absolument elle continue à progresser
régulièrement donc là si on prend ces
dernières semaines c'est à dire depuis
le début de la guerre en Ukraine et 4
points c'est la seule candidate qui en
fait en dynamique positive avec Jean-Luc
Mélenchon mais qui partait d'un peu plus
bas ce qu'il a mis dans une position
aujourd'hui relativement confortable
avec deux mouvements intéressants le
premier c'est qu'elle arrive à
reconsoluer son socle de premier tour en
2017 c'était électorat qui était un peu
tenté quand même il faut le dire par un
vote Éric Zemmour tout au long de la
campagne qu'il a revient petit à petit
sur un vote Marine Le Pen et puis
deuxième point et là c'est assez nouveau
un électorat assez âgé traditionnel de
droite qui avait voté François Fillon
2017 de plus en plus se laisse tenter
par ce vote Marine Le Pen il y a
toujours eu un peu une difficulté pour
cette électorat franchir le pas et
d'aller jusqu'à mettre un bulletin RN
dans l'urne aujourd'hui face à une
Marine Le Pen on y Rev sera un peu
recentré dans le jeu politique c'est
moins compliqué de passer cette étape là
et ça fait du coup un réservoir devoir
en plus pour Marine Le Pen effectivement
ce sera l'un des éléments qu'on va
analyser ensemble claire Chartier elle
fait une bonne campagne tout simplement
on peut on peut dire ça c'est si on
essaye de poser un regard un peu général
sur sur cette troisième campagne
présidentielle de Marine Le Pen
absolument alors déjà il y a quand même
à mon avis une raison assez simple mais
qui est très puissante dans le contexte
français c'est que Marine Le Pen on n'a
pas encore essayé en fait l'extrême
droite on n'a pas encore essayé et dans
un contexte où les les électeurs enfin
et l'opinion publique et même très
défiante envers les politiques beaucoup
sont revenus de tout en quelque sorte et
se disent bah pourquoi pas des gens qui
n'ont pas dans en tête
la formule extrême droite mais qui se
disent pourquoi pas essayer une nouvelle
solution ça c'est le premier point qui
me semble simple mais assez puissant
comme ressort le deuxième c'est qu'en
effet je pense que on a dit on a cru que
il y a quelques années donc en 2017 que
Marine Le Pen n'avait pas vraiment envie
du pouvoir et en fait on s'est trompé
parce que depuis 2017 et bien elle a
construit toute une stratégie très
cohérente et qu'elle a respecté elle
s'est fait épauler
depuis 2017 je vous laisse pas trop
avancer parce qu'on y reviendra en
détail ensemble du coup on est en train
de mesurer le fruit de tout ce travail
parce qu'effectivement visiblement elle
a fourni un énorme travail et pas depuis
aujourd'hui et pas depuis il y a un mois
effectivement et alors ce qui est ce qui
m'intéresse aussi alors là c'est
beaucoup plus court thermiste la
réflexion que je fais à one Locker c'est
c'est depuis le début de cette guerre en
Ukraine enfin il y avait quand même un
handicap qui pouvait être un boulet pour
Marine Le Pen c'est sa poutine au fini
ou en tout cas sa relation avec le
président russe cette photo avec lui qui
a du Cala dû sortir de d'un trac de
campagne enfin en ne distribuant pas le
tract et on voit pas d'impact comment
vous l'expliquer ça
d'abord il y a un phénomène sociologique
qu'on connaît bien et qu'on ne veut pas
accepter à chaque fois c'est que
l'électorat le pénis n'est pas
l'électorat de la France c'est un
électorat spécifique qui se comporte de
façon spécifique il n'est pas gêné par
le fait que Marine Le Pen est accusé
d'avoir pris de l'argent au Parlement
européen il n'est pas gêné par tout un
tas de révélations sur les élus le pénis
depuis des années des années c'est quand
même le les élus qui ont fait le plus de
je dirais de d'un cartable à la loi
lorsqu'ils sont élus certains ont pris
un million d'euros etc ça ne gêne pas
cette électorat c'est une première chose
nous avons là un électorat qui est
fidèle qui se détermine longtemps en
amont qui se détermine longtemps en
avance et qui a une forme de fidélité à
quelque chose qui va au-delà de la
politique court thermiste d'une campagne
et c'est la force vous l'avez un peu dit
en creux de Marine Le Pen c'est qu'elle
est là depuis longtemps il y a quelque
chose son père dirait durée le fait de
durer dans le temps il a duré dans le
temps elle est là aussi depuis longtemps
depuis 2002 on l'a vu arriver le 21
avril 2002 je le rappelle elle est à la
tête du parti depuis 2011 c'est sa
troisième campagne elle est implantée et
quelque part son électorat lui fait
confiance et donc c'est plus fort que la
guerre en Ukraine et ce que ça pourrait
créer quoi que les attaques du système
n'oubliez jamais ce mot les attaques
sont celles du système on a affaire un
électorat qui est mécontent qui est un
électoral je dirais de la politique du
ressentiment qui va chercher sur
internet un certain nombre de réponses à
des questions simples et les réponses
simples Marine Le Pen et le penisme lui
apporte des éléments réponse simple
depuis plus de 40 ans aujourd'hui et
donc on a une longue durée on est dans
la longue durée contrairement à Éric
Zemmour qui lui était un flash ou une
bulle médiatique qui a fait illusion
pendant six mois parce que ça amusé le
giron médiatique un certain nombre
d'analystes et je faisais partie disait
les émotions ne pèsent rien en réalité
politiquement tout comme Marion maréchal
ça ne pèse rien c'est médiatiquement
c'est intéressant c'est rigolo il y a
pas de socle électoral solide d'environ
10% sociologiquement c'est l'extrême
droite française des vieux de plus de 60
ans qui et qui s'amuse à voter à droite
pour montrer qu'ils sont très à droite
c'est le Le Pen 1 c'est le premier
électoral Eupen le deuxième et troisième
c'est Marine Le Pen qui les a et tu
auras plus populiste les jeunes les
femmes tous les gens qui sont mécontents
les ouvriers les employés et là il y a
un socle électoral sociologique fort qui
ne se contentent pas de regarder
l'actualité pour savoir ce qu'il va
voter ça fait longtemps qu'il était le
pénis et on le voyait avant l'effet
Zemmour on avait déjà les mêmes sondages
soit 55 45 Macron Le Pen au deuxième
tour on revient un an avant alors ça on
y revient on y reviendra même si on va
être évidemment très prudent sur le le
second tour voilà on va pas faire comme
s'ils étaient déjà qualifiés et Emmanuel
Macron et Marine Le Pen a encore pas mal
d'incertitudes Laetitia moi je trouve
très intéressant ce que vous venez de
dire c'est effectivement le vote de la
France en colère Marine Le Pen et quand
on écoute steward show là dans le sujet
d'un production à ce débat c'est aussi
très intéressant parce que peu
d'observateurs vont sur ce terrain là
mais il existe une jonction des pôles
une jonction des extrêmes c'est à dire
que comme disait des électeurs de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui a priori sont les
ennemis du pôle qui est vraiment
diamétralement opposé au leurre peuvent
aller aussi chez Marine Le Pen pourquoi
parce que c'est la colère qui est
cristallisée et cette se ressentiment
très bien décrit par Cynthia Fleury si
vous voulez aller plus loin qui est
entretenu aussi par les deux camps mais
qui fait qu'à un moment donné on peut
avoir un glissement de terrain qui est
quand même paradoxal théoriquement et on
se on retrouve quand même des électeurs
qui effectivement passent d'un pôle à
l'autre et ce qui amène évidemment les
leaders de la France insoumise à
répondre régulièrement à cette question
le dernier en date c'était Adrien
cadenas sur sur France Info qui dit
voter Marine Le Pen n'est pas une option
pour elle et fille en cas de duel Macron
Le Pen aux second tour c'est vraiment la
la question récurrente évidemment qu'il
aurait posé alors on va revenir sur la
thématique que vous avez abordé
troisième campagne et
les erreurs et je propose que
qu'Alexandre Poussard nous rejoignent on
apprend tous de nos erreurs Alexandre ça
c'est une bonne Maxime et on peut dire
que elle en avait quand même commis pas
mal entre les deux tours là on est entre
les deux tours de 2017 de 2017 qui avait
pourtant bien commencé pour Marine Le
Pen avec une bonne séquence autour de
l'usine Whirlpool à Amiens menacé de
délocalisation en Pologne Emmanuel
Macron décide de se rendre à Amiens à
l'époque pour rencontrer dans des
bureaux des représentants des salariés
et ce jour-là Marine Le Pen à la
surprise générale elle décide elle aussi
d'aller devant l'usine Whirlpool sur le
sur le piquet de grève et elle reçoit
une ovation de la part des grévistes
souvenez-vous
Emmanuel Macron venez ici et qu'il
entendait pas rencontrer les salariés
qu'il entendait pas venir sur ce piquet
de grève mais qu'il allait dans un à
l'abri dans je ne sais quelle salle de
la Chambre de commerce pour rencontrer
deux trois personnes triées sur le volet
et bien j'ai trouvé que c'était une
preuve
d'elle à l'égard de ce que vivent les
salariés de Whirlpool que j'ai décidé de
sortir de mon conseil stratégique est de
venir vous voir voilà ça fait un peu
partie du théâtre de l'entre-deux tours
alors ce contre-pied de Marine Le Pen ce
jour-là il oblige Emmanuel Macron à
venir lui aussi l'après-midi sur le pic
et grève et à subir cette fois-ci les
hués des grévistes de Whirlpool autre
temps fort dans l'entre deux tours pour
Marine Le Pen et bien le ralliement de
Nicolas Dupont-Aignan le candidat de
Debout la France qui en 2017 avait quand
même fait 5% des voix au premier tour
près de 5% et elle annonce quel le
nommera Premier ministre si jamais elle
est élue ça c'est pour les temps forts
vient ensuite le débat de
l'entre-deux-tours face à Emmanuel
Macron et c'est là que ça se gâte pour
Marine Le Pen car elle s'en mêle un peu
les pinceaux dans ce débat notamment sur
la sortie de l'euro on ne sait pas
vraiment si elle veut sortir de l'euro
vous proposez bien de sortir de l'euro
non je vais renégocier pour que l'euro
on sent libère et on le transforme en
monnaie commune c'est ce qu'il a existé
il était avant qu'il devienne la monnaie
de la France avec de l'euro les choses
soient très claires non on ne paiera pas
avec de l'euro
les banques centrales pairont avec de
l'euro si elles le souhaitent et voilà
Marine Le Pen un peu confuse dans ce
débat d'entre eux Emmanuel Macron sait
appuyer là où ça fait mal
vous êtes en train de lire une fiche qui
ne correspond pas au dossier que vous
avez cité c'est triste pour vous parce
que ça montre votre impréparation à nos
concitoyens et la préparation de Marine
Le Pen c'est ce que beaucoup ont retenu
de ce débat de l'entre-deux-tours et ça
c'est ressenti dans les sondages sur
cette période car Marine Le Pen était
sur une bonne dynamique un juste après
le premier tour les cas commencer à se
resserrer et ensuite après le débat de
l'entre-deux tours et bien ça c'est
effondré pour Marine Le Pen et le
résultat du son retour était encore plus
lourd que prévu puisqu'elle n'a récolté
à l'époque que 33% des voix merci
beaucoup Alexandre pour pour ce voilà ça
c'est toujours bien de revoir des
archives comme celle-là et alors vous
nous le disiez tout à l'heure claire
sortie elle a travaillé depuis alors sur
quoi il y avait qui d'ailleurs c'est
intéressant c'est intéressant de
reparler ce débat parce qu'effectivement
au terme de ce débat qui était jugé de
l'ordre du naufrage par tous les
commentateurs et par des gens à
l'intérieur aussi du Harn on lui a
beaucoup reproché et donc on taxé Marine
Le Pen de dilettante enfin qui
travaillait pas assez etc elle avait pas
bossé ses dossiers bon et en fait la
Marine Le Pen que l'on a vu toutes ces
années ne correspond pas tellement on
porterait pendant l'adresse à ce
moment-là et elle s'est fait épauler
effectivement par un petit cénacle de
gens qui quand même incarnent quand même
un peu le système malgré tout puisque ce
sont des politiciens des énarques des
hauts fonctionnaires donc assez
paradoxal et ce petit groupe qui s'est
baptisé les Horaces qui fonctionnaient
en marge du RN la conseiller ils ont eu
des réunions très régulières je croyais
hebdomadaire et de telle sorte que ils
l'ont amené à adopter une stratégie je
dirais d'atténuation sur la forme mais
pas sur le fond donc par exemple elle a
une tactique effectivement de diversion
par euphémisation
alors notamment bon sur l'immigration
elle en parle peu aujourd'hui mais en
fait quand on regarde dans le détail
effectivement la doctrine n'a pas changé
l'Europe on l'évoquait à l'instant elle
dit on va pas sortir de l'Union
européenne mais tout ce qu'elle dit
finalement équivaut à une sortie de
l'Union européenne on peut y venir dans
le détail mais enfin c'est vraiment
exactement ce que ça veut dire là et
aussi ses propositions amen à non
seulement à une révision enfin même plus
qu'une révision de la Constitution si on
la suit dans les domaines qu'elle avance
l'immigration et donc Europe etc il
faudrait changer de constitution donc en
fait il changerait la Constitution qui
change notamment le préambule donc c'est
absolument énorme et donc c'est vraiment
toute une stratégie qui est la
développée et ce qui est intéressant
c'est que dans toute l'histoire des
populismes normalement pour lorsqu'ils
veulent conquérir le pouvoir les
populistes sont obligés d'arrondir
finement les angles pour élargir leur
base et je pense d'ailleurs qu'elle est
elle a un peu élargi sa base on le
voyait notamment auprès des électeurs LR
donc au delà de des filiales que vous
évoquiez et au risque évidemment de
perdre ces fameux fidèles et donc là
elle ne les perd pas et je trouve que
c'est vraiment intéressant d'un point de
vue politique pourquoi parce que
effectivement alors que face à elle un
Emmanuel Macron parle à la tête elle
elle sait parler en fait aux affects à
l'estomac d'une France double la France
de la contestation de la colère et puis
aussi la France de la désillusion et
c'est deux français d'après une enquête
passionnante qui a été publiée par un
sac de réflexion qui s'appelle destin
commun il y a peu de temps cette France
là elle représente une majorité de
Français donc on peut quand même se dire
qu'effectivement là il y a un creusé à
travailler alors il y a une question je
dois vous poser pirater un Bartoli on
évoque on l'a dit plusieurs fois sur ce
plateau à la fois le vote d'adhésion et
le taux de rejet enfin les facteurs de
rejet d'une personnalité politique
est-ce que effectivement Marine Le Pen a
gobé une partie de ces facteurs de rejet
qui qui font que malgré tout l'opinion à
cette capacité à se mobiliser s'il y a
le risque qu'elle l'élection
présidentielle c'est exactement ce qui
s'est passé au cours de cette campagne
et c'est pour ça que la candidature
exemmour lui a pris beaucoup de voix au
début de la campagne mais aujourd'hui
c'est presque un atout en terme d'image
personnelle si elle réussit à aller
jusqu'au second tour pourquoi parce que
aujourd'hui quand on interroge des
électeurs de gauche mais également du
centre et pour une partie des électeurs
de droite il y a un épouvantail dans la
campagne il s'appelle Eric Zemmour plus
du tout Marine Le Pen ce qui était le
cas lorsqu'on posait la question au tout
début de la campagne et qu'elle était la
seule candidate d'extrême droite donc il
y a un candidat qui polarise le rejet et
par ailleurs elle a réussi à adoucir
énormément son image auprès des
différents électorats qu'il a regardent
un peu sur le fond beaucoup aussi sur la
forme quand on voit Marine Le Pen plus
sage plus aguerri avec plus de distance
par rapport aux choses qui est presque
la candidate la plus calme dans ce
qu'elle propose un effet qui s'appelle
dans le monde anglo-saxon l'effet
underdog mais qui en fait un effet chira
95 c'est à dire elle a été trahie par
tous donc elle suscite une forme de
compassion c'est quelque chose qui
nourrit son image et nourrir son image
c'est la première étape vers un vote
alors de premier ou de ou de second tour
et c'est ce qu'on voit actuellement dans
les enquêtes ouais c'est vraiment
passionnant il y a une autre dimension
qui est très intéressante dans la
dynamique qui porte Marine Le Pen
Laetitia c'est la banalisation à dire de
certains thèmes qui choquaient l'option
on appelle ça je l'ai appris grâce à
vous cet après-midi je vais être très
honnête on appelle ça la fenêtre
d'overton
le cœur que j'ai entendu sur France Info
un matin et oui je me suis intéressé
cette théorie à la base c'est une
théorie développée par les lobéistes aux
États-Unis pour imposer dans le débat
public faire passer leur proposition qui
a priori n'était pas acceptable en fait
la fenêtre d'overton c'est je vais vous
donner la définition exacte de base en
tout cas l'horizon de l'acceptable en
politique et qui varie sur un axe allant
du plus libre au moins libre
en gros c'est tout ce qu'on peut dire ou
pas dans le champ politique et après les
lobbyistes aux États-Unis les populistes
s'en sont emparés souvent avec une
technique un peu particulière celle du
rire pour faire passer davantage plus
facilement des idées souvent
nauséesabondes et bien sûr ensuite la
droite
ultra nationaliste s'en est emparé à son
tour
en France c'est très clair on constate
tout le monde peut le faire que le débat
politique et public a glissé à droite
offrant une plus grande place à des
idées qui jusqu'à maintenant étaient
se confronter à un plafond de verre
exemple la théorie du Grand remplacement
théorie raciste de Renault Camus qui a
été répété des centaines de fois je n'ai
pas compté mais serait intéressant de
savoir combien de fois Eric Zemmour a
répété cette cette théorie et puis il y
a aussi les journalistes bien sûr qu'ils
l'ont repris alors souvent pour la
dénoncer ou va les Pécresse par exemple
qui la reprise pour alors on n'a pas le
son transparent avec les téléspectateurs
mais c'est effectivement sa formule elle
était ambigu lors de lors de son
maladroit on peut dire maladroit
ambiguïté volontaire ou pas mais en tout
cas elle était c'était un cadeau fait
rire
suivant on a parlé comme ça mais comme
pour les journalistes si vous voulez le
problème c'est que on nomme cette
théorie donc on la met factuellement
dans le débat politique et public pour
la dénoncer sauf que en la nommant on
lui donne une existence encore une fois
concrète et le responsable de encore une
fois de cet élargissement de la fenêtre
d'overton je sais pas si on peut dire
comme ça bien sûr c'est Éric Zemmour
mais pas que lui a toujours
revendiqué qu'il se battait pour cette
ce combat idéologique qu'il était à
chevalier ce combat idéologique depuis
qu'il est journaliste donc ça fait 30
ans qu'il labour le terrain mais si on
ne lui donnait pas d'opportunités et de
place dans les médias ça aurait été plus
difficile je vous rappelle qu'il était
journaliste au Figaro puis à cnews et
c'est assez news qu'il a vraiment
développé cette idée là qu'il a été
sur France 2 dans l'émission
dans ces propos pour ces propos à ses
news il est condamné et pour la première
fois un homme journaliste polémiste
éditorialiste et condamné mais
[Musique]
intervention c'est les minorités actives
font utilisent cette théorie de la
fenêtre d'overton en utilisant du
vocabulaire reconnaissable en le
martelant et vous vous rendrez compte
que le problème de l'immigration la sécu
la sécurité c'est la première des
libertés
1983-196 six Vitas et Front national
donc c'était exactement cette
théorisation de la fenêtre d'oerton on
ouvrait une fenêtre dans un coin et on
faisait en sorte que ça devienne
acceptable le problème de l'immigration
1983 avant c'était pas un problème
c'était une chance l'immigration pour la
France et c'est devenu un problème donc
théorie des minorités actives plus vous
avez raison fenêtre d'overton ouverte
notamment par Éric Zemmour et l'Empire
Bolloré soyons très clair derrière c'est
à dire l'ensemble qui a été le
l'ensemble Canal+ et tout un certain
nombre de choses c'est un combat
sociologique et politique c'est
grahamshi 1920 1930 le combat sémantique
précède le combat politique le combat
culturel sur les mots qu'on sait précède
les victoires politiques et donc tout
pour répondre à votre question toutes
les forces politiques et sociales ont
tendance à ouvrir leurs fenêtres
d'overton l'extrême gauche a pu l'ouvrir
à une époque c'est à dire l'égalité pour
tous plus de frontières du tout c'était
des fenêtres d'overton je n'étais pas
admis comme tel c'est devenu quelque
chose c'est pourquoi pas l'égalité
complète les féministes ouvrent les
fenêtres ouvertton égalité complète en
tout lieu voilà et chaque sphère sociale
et moment social va ouvrir certaines
fenêtres pour des minorités actives qui
vont être agissantes en ce moment on a
d'un côté ce que certains appellent les
woks alors en tant que chercheur
sciences sociales je suis forcément wooc
puisque je m'intéresse à tout ce qui est
nouveau dans la société c'est mon job je
suis entre guillemets c'est ça que je
dois faire je regarde tout ce qui émerge
dans la société comme les sondeurs et
donc je suis awake ça vient de là je
suis ouvert aux nouveautés sociétales
parce qu'on appelle les signaux faibles
toute personne qui serait un chercheur
et qui ne serait pas wok serait un
mauvais chercheur donc quelque part ou
un journaliste qui ne serait pas oups
serait un mauvais journaliste donc là
aussi on voit bien que mais après on
sait bien que le mot a été récupéré et
vider de son sens premier et donc là il
y a une autre théorie c'est ouf ou
posez-vous les frontières symboliques et
frontières en termes de mots le mot walk
aurait dû aurait dû être un mot ouvert
un mot qui ouvrait vers une nouvelle
façon de considérer la société il a été
récupéré par une autre minorité active
parce que celle en gros du woky's tel
que l'extrême droite n'est pas assez
puissant en ce moment dans les médias
n'a pas réussi à imposer son agenda
l'agenda a été imposé par une partie de
la droite extrême qui a fait du mot wok
un autre mot je vais vous donner un
exemple pour que vous compreniez bien
dans les années 80 on parlait des Arabes
dans les banlieues eux-mêmes se sont
appelés les rebeu ils ont renversé c'est
ce qu'on appelle l'exo catégorisation en
deux catégorisation on rentre récupère
le mot on le remet à l'endroit on le met
dans l'autre sens pour se l'approprier
et bien ensuite on a mis rebeu et
ensuite vous vous pouvez regarder le mot
se renverse à chaque fois qu'il est
utilisé par l'un ou l'autre des champs
sémantique et politique OK et la
politique c'est de la sémantique et
c'est l'accepte vous l'avez dit
Eric Zemmour a rendu Marine Le Pen très
sympathique ça se trouve amène au cœur
de notre sujet elle dit tout ça depuis
20 ans elle a déjà fait le travail elle
a récupéré ce que la minorité active qui
était Front national avait fait avec
l'islam et en parlant 2008 la préférence
nationale 95 elle a fait tout le travail
et donc elle arrive aujourd'hui en
pouvant exactement ce que vous avez dit
être plus consensuel plus normal en
récupérant ce qu'a fait le travail de
Zemmour j'ai même parlé de le lièvre
Zemmour il ouvre il court devant il
ouvre une possibilité et Marine Le Pen
vient de récupérer de vont-ils avoir à
dire après ça à cette démonstration
allez-y il me semble intéressant de
noter dans le dans le jeu politique
entre Rick Zemmour et Marine Le Pen
Eric Zemmour il est initise la question
de l'étranger l'immigration Marine Le
Pen jusqu'en 2015 elle parlait des
Français de souche et ensuite elle a
cessé d'en parler en fait elle est
passée sur un registre cultureliste
alors qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça veut
dire vous présenter pas l'immigration de
la même façon et donc c'est moins
repoussoir d'une certaine manière vous
présenter l'immigration comme un
problème économique une sorte de
concurrence entre
salariés travailleurs et ça c'est un
message qui peut effectivement toucher
plus largement lorsque vous restez sur
le le registre ethnique et c'est le cas
d'Éric Zemmour parce que la grande
erreur de à mon sens d'Éric Zemmour
c'est que eczéma un esprit de système et
donc sa vision elle est épuisante en ce
sens-là c'est qu'elle est systémique
donc elle se vraiment elle est
parfaitement cohérente dans son dans son
monde à lui mais il n'en est pas sorti
du tout c'est ça qui l'a fait comme être
des erreurs en disant par exemple les
Ukrainiens ils doivent pas venir en
France donc ça a été très très mal perçu
Marine Le Pen a la différence elle a
montré aussi qu'elle savait
remarquablement s'adapter donc elle a
mis un peu sous boissons la thématique
migration au départ elle était partie
sur une thématique très intéressante qui
était les libertés parce qu'on était
dans un contexte d'antivax plus ça lui
permettait de répondre à Macron sur son
libéralisme elle voulait être la
présidente des libertés françaises
disaient-elles et puis ensuite elle est
passée sur le pouvoir d'achat dès
septembre parce qu'elle a senti avec son
petit conclave de conseiller que c'était
là qu'il fallait aller et du coup elle a
complètement reformaté sa campagne donc
là aussi voilà pourquoi elle mène une
bonne campagne parce qu'elle a su
s'ajuster elle a su être mobile ce qui
n'est pas du tout le cas de zéro est-ce
qu'il ne pouvait pas l'être le rappeler
et vous l'avez fait d'ailleurs dans
votre titre Thomas que c'est l'effet
Canada Dry c'est-à-dire que le premier
Zemmour et le même que le programme de
Marine Le Pen parce que j'entends moi
parfois des journalistes et observateurs
être dupe de cette communication de
Marine Le Pen or c'est le même programme
depuis derrière la normalisation un
programme d'extrême droite voilà
pour l'avoir un peu étudié celui de
Marine Le Pen a évolué sur quelques
points seulement qui font une légère
différence et qui font que en effet
comme vous venez le rappeler Éric
Zemmour est enfermé dans un registre
très idéologique que Jean-Marie Le Pen
n'avait pas que Bruno maigreavait et
Marine Le Pen comme Jean-Marie Le Pen et
beaucoup plus malléable elle est d'abord
une porte-parole elle veut d'abord
gagner et ensuite une femme de 1968 elle
l'immigration tous ces sujets c'est des
sujets potentiels c'est pas son seul
sujet c'est donc elle est devenue multi
sujet et là-dessus même son programme
reste un programme d'extrême droite sur
bien des sujets notamment les libertés
vous avez raison mais c'est aussi
envoyer des des signaux qui disent je
m'occupe de vous je m'occupe pas d'abord
effectivement alors on revient à cet
électorat populaire et ça n'a pas
échappé évidemment à plusieurs candidats
et candidats qui en écoute Nathalie
Arthaud elle avait un message pour les
ouvriers ce matin
ce qui effectivement vote pour Marine Le
Pen abeille se trompe qu'est-ce que vous
voulez que je vous dise il se trompe
parce que Marine Le Pen elle n'est pas
du côté des classes populaires et du
monde du travail il y a encore une fois
vous savez quand on est anti immigré on
est anti ouvriers parce que voilà le
monde du travail il est composé beaucoup
de travailleurs et de travailleurs
immigrés et heureusement qu'ils sont là
pour faire tourner les hôpitaux les
chantiers etc autre réaction ce matin
elle est signée du candidat communiste
cette fois-ci Fabien Roussel écouter
on écoute Fabien Roussel adresse aux
électeurs d'extrême droite il y en a qui
nous écoutent l'extrême droite en France
n'a jamais été aussi haut ces 15 20
dernières années pour qu'elle qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont apporté à la France qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont apporté comme progrès pour le
monde du travail pour les salaires pour
le mieux vivre pour notre industrie que
dalle votez pour l'extrême droite ça ne
rapporte rien imaginez en retour car la
place de l'extrême droite qui est
aujourd'hui à 15 20% imaginaire un parti
communiste qui se trouve lui à 15-20% et
bien quand c'était le cas dans notre
pays et il y a eu du progrès social
parce que nous avons fait à chaque fois
le choix du rassemblement de la gauche
et nous avons fait à chaque fois le
choix du monde du travail de travailler
avec le mouvement social et de gagner
alors voter pour l'extrême droite ça ne
sert à rien ça pose aussi la question
alors c'est pas ce que disait Fabien
Roussel de cette éternel plafond de
verre et on va terminer cette partie de
débat consacrée à Marine Le Pen
là-dessus pierre Adrien Bartoli sur les
réservoirs de suffrage et là encore on
est prudent on parle à chaque débat
politique on parle des indécis on parle
de de l'abstention potentielle mais les
réservoirs de suffrages pour une Marine
Le Pen entre les deux tours comment vous
l'analysez ça les réservoirs ils sont
importants et ils sont beaucoup plus
importants que ce qui s'est passé il y a
5 ans déjà il y a un socle nous on a
xemmour à 10% aujourd'hui c'est 10% qui
se reportent presque automatiquement sur
Marine Le Pen en cas de seconde tour
donc pas d'abstention et pas de vote
pour Emmanuel Macron ça ça se fait assez
naturellement on a un pan des électeurs
Valérie Pécresse qui de toute façon sont
dans du anti et vont aller voter pour
Marine Le Pen au second tour si elle
devait être au second tour évidemment et
puis surtout un second tour ça se joue
sur les votants mais également sur les
abstentionnistes et la gauche n'a pas
envie aujourd'hui d'aller voter on est
entre 40 et 50% des électeurs de gauche
qui dans un cadre dans le cas d'un duel
entre Emmanuel Macron et Marine Le Pen
se disent j'ai déjà voté utile il y a
cinq ans maintenant je vais m'abstenir
et ne pas aller voter et parfois même il
y a 20 ans aussi exactement et donc on
se retrouve dans une situation où on a
certes aujourd'hui toujours une avantage
pour Emmanuel Macron dans cette
hypothétique second tour mais un écart
qui se restreint de plus en plus elle
peut gagner on peut dire les choses
comme ça En tout cas on est on est à
l'orée d'un accident politique potentiel
c'est évident ce que vient de de
rappeler ici la situation et qu'on voit
dans les dans les études qualitatives
qu'on peut faire c'est un nombre
croissant de gens qui disent on ne
mourra plus à voter le genre de gauche
et du centre qui on n'aura plus à voter
pour le libéralisme inconnus ça fait
trois fois que je le fais je ne vois
plus au deuxième tour pour le moins pire
parce que ça commence à bien faire donc
on a une courbe qui est ascendante et
donc une baisse phénoménale du soutien
Macron deuxième tour et on a en effet ce
que j'appelle l'effet lièvre de Zemmour
c'est que Zemmour en allant plus loin
dans la fenêtre d'overton rendant
sympathique quasiment aux yeux de bien
des Français la posture de Marine Le Pen
parce que quelque part elle est plus
sympa que lui et bien a ouvert un champ
en effet où Marine Le Pen aujourd'hui
moi je dis il y a un accident politique
potentiel en effet claire Chartier je
reprends le
de nos confrères du monde qui disent que
c'est l'analyse Marine Le Pen vise la
mise en place d'un État autoritaire
est-ce que vous vous dites ça ça rejoint
un peu ce que vous évoquiez sur la
réforme constitutionnelle le fait de
passer par un référendum pour pour
finalement contourner le Conseil
constitutionnel enfin il y a un certain
nombre de
tout fondamentaux qui sont contenus dans
notre Constitution et qui correspondent
aussi aux principes fondamentaux
reconnus par les pays européens
effectivement donc c'est vraiment une de
ce point de vue là une révolution
majeure mais je reprends ce qu'on disait
tout à l'heure cette idée de d'État de
droit cette notion-là elle est assez
d'une certaine manière elle est quand
même assez intellectuelle et je ne suis
pas sûr nous ça nous anime beaucoup
parce que c'est le cœur de la démocratie
mais comme on fait pas tellement de
pédagogie sur cette question là le lien
entre atteinte ou contre-pouvoir état de
droits et la démocratie tel qu'on la
voit aujourd'hui en Ukraine lorsqu'elle
est atteinte comme ça dans sa chair
comme il y a pas de pédagogie les
manigent ne font pas forcément le lien
et donc quand on leur dit ça ils se
disent bah ouais ça c'est un peu confus
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est ce qu'elle
me propose pour ma réalité du quotidien
et comme elle a fait une campagne très
grande proximité franchement elle a
vraiment parlé aux gens dans l'ordre
dans leur réalité vécue mais c'est ça
qui porte c'est pas les débats qui
peuvent paraître très intelligents
c'est quelque chose que nous utilisons
énormément journaliste commentateurs etc
chez les Français il y a moins de la
moitié qui considère que l'équivage
gauche droite s'impose encore parce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure et tout à
fait juste il y a des gens peut-être pas
des gens Mélenchon qui vont voter
massivement pour Marine Le Pen mais
beaucoup de gens qui votent Mélenchon
vont s'abstenir pour laisser et c'est
l'abstention différentielle qui fait
désormais les candidatures et qui fait
les victoires c'est le fait que le camp
de gauche s'abstient pour laisser
Sarkozy gagner le camp de droite c'est
absolu pour laisser au lendemain si
jamais le camp du centre gauche ça tient
bien Marine Le Pen pourrait gagner et en
effet ça ne fait pas peur à au camp de
Marine Le Pen un état plus autoritaire
c'est même une demande forte pour 40%
des Français on va prendre 5 minutes
pour pour terminer parler d'une autre
candidate qui était à l'opposé de
l'échiquier politique et de la dynamique
de campagne c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire c'est Anne Hidalgo à la peine
depuis le lancement de cette
présidentielle je vous propose avant de
vous donner la parole aux uns et aux
autres d'écouter
qui vise le candidat président de droite
et de droite dit-elle et on veut nous
expliquer que ça n'existerait pas dans
le pays on veut nous expliquer et
culpabiliser ces gens-là et traiter ce
qui les aident de lâche c'est ça le
projet d'Emmanuel Macron c'est ça cette
fameuse France qui marcherait sur deux
jambes la jambe gauche et la jambe
droite là il saute à cloche-pied mais
alors à cloche-pied avec son pied droit
et il fait le grand dépassement de la
droite par la droite
5% d'intention de vote dans votre
dernier études à risque interactive pour
pour challenge si on parle de je sais
pas si on peut employer le terme de
dynamique de campagne mais quel a été
son plus haut niveau
elle est assez haut avant l'entrée en
campagne de Christiane Taubira 5% en
fait
mais le problème c'est qu'elle perd
c'est quelques points qu'elle avait
réussi à grappiller à ce moment-là au
profit de et à nous les retrouve jamais
y compris après sa sortie de la course
présidentielle il y a un chiffre qui
incarne bien ce qui se passe au sein de
l'esprit des électorats socialistes en
2017 Benoît Hamon fait 6,4 % parmi ces
6,4% aujourd'hui 11 % porte leur scrutin
leur suffrage sur un Hidalgo
c'est-à-dire que même sur une base
extrêmement faible déjà à l'époque des
lecteurs on est presque à 1 sur 10 qui
persiste à voter pour la candidate
socialiste quand les autres vont vers
les différents candidats que sont
Jean-Luc Mélenchon Yannick Jadot
Emmanuel Macron donc en fait ce socle
d'électeurs socialiste ils existent dans
l'opinion parce que c'est des gens qui
n'ont pas disparu en revanche il se
répartissent tellement entre les autres
candidats et l'abstention parce qu'ils
trouvent pas chaussures à leurs pieds
qu'au fond la candidate investi par le
Parti socialiste fait un score
effectivement très faible mais il y aura
une grande responsabilité du Parti
socialiste et Dani dalgo parce qu'à
plusieurs reprises il y a des tentatives
de de la sortir du jeu et de la faire
décrocher et elle n'a toujours refusé
donc si vous voulez elle sur les
sondages qui seraient déficients on
verra bien ce qui se passe dans 10 jours
mais il y aura une responsabilité énorme
parce que comme vous le disiez les
électeurs de gauche existent quand on
regarde les élections locales ils
existent et donc que va dire le Parti
socialiste à ces électeurs au lendemain
du premier tour si les catastrophique
comme l'annoncent les sondages et que
dira à GO claire Chartier elle a jamais
vraiment bénéficié d'un de d'une
impulsion d'un appel d'air dans cette
campagne déjà on cherchait la goût
chercher son candidat la Gaule démocrate
chercher son candidat donc on en parlait
tout à l'heure à un moment on a pensé à
Cazeneuve qui avait une toute autre
image où finalement il est pas allé elle
elle était quand même très fortement
lesté de ça de sa réputation parisienne
de passionnats
anti-automobile donc ça ça ne les dépend
je crois que c'est aussi le reflet quand
même d'un de la vraie enfin je sais pas
si on peut parler de naufrage mais en
tout cas de la très grosse difficulté de
la sociale démocratie en France qui n'a
pas su se renouveler même sur le plan
idéologique le renouvellement il s'est
plutôt trouvé à l'extrême en tout cas à
la gauche il y a beaucoup beaucoup de
productions intellectuelles de ce côté
là puis c'est vrai que bon bah dans ce
camp là rien n'a émergé les productions
ont vraiment peinées
qui va pas voter Emmanuel Macron donc il
va rester chez elle non finalement il
aurait été beaucoup plus drôle que ce
soit François Hollande parce qu'il a
failli aller encore il y a peu de temps
parce qu'il était il est quand même prêt
à aller très loin donc je pense que si
ça se trouve il aurait fait plus parce
que il y avait un public pour ça savoir
jusqu'où ça pouvait aller François
Hollande qui se pose déjà en recours de
de l'après présidentielle
Erwan Leclerc un mot sur sur un
hidalgool le pouvoir d'achat on en
parlait ça aurait pu être son thème
central d'une certaine façon d'ailleurs
quand elle démarre sa campagne ça mesure
phare c'est doublé le salaire des profs
sur la durée de son quinquennat
il y a une erreur stratégique d'une
certaine façon là une erreur historique
en réalité le Parti socialiste est
quelque part mort le 21 avril 2002 et il
n'a pas voulu l'admettre il est devenu à
ce moment-là une sorte de zombie et
depuis on voit bien qu'il y a trois
France politique qui sur le terrain sont
très présentes qui gagnent les
municipales et les régionales elle est
où ce qu'il en reste le PS ou ce qu'il
en reste avec beaucoup d'élus et puis
les écologistes qui commencent à devenir
un peu une force politique municipale
mais pas tellement plus puis il y a
trois forces politiques nationales qui
sont aujourd'hui Emmanuel Macron qui a
personne sur le terrain Marine Le Pen
qui a perdu la moitié de ses élus sur le
terrain et Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui a
quasiment personne sur le terrain non
plus donc on a une France qui
sociologiquement et politiquement est
scindé en deux entre des gens à qui on
fait confiance au plus proche pour gérer
au quotidien et des gens à qui on fait
un peu confiance au niveau national et
ça le Parti socialiste ne l'ayant pas
compris n'ayant rien renouvelé de son
idée l'idéal démocratique bien on voit
madame Hidalgo en effet continuer à
faire ce que la gauche morale faisait
dans les années 80 ça marchait à
l'époque aujourd'hui c'était à la
rigueur inaudible c'est-à-dire que dire
que la droite est méchante parce qu'elle
est à droite c'est relativement peu
audible même de la part de Anne Hidalgo
qui par ailleurs a été élu maire de
Paris comme à Rennes comme à Nantes
comme dans plein de grandes villes ce
sont des gens proches de Anne Hidalgo
qui gère les villes mais par contre on
ne leur fait plus confiance
pour gérer la crise mondiale qui est
devant nous et les crises mondiales qui
sont devant nous donc là il y a un
déficit de compréhension je dirais
historique et pas seulement politique et
c'est intéressant on l'a déjà dit parce
que on peut même considérer que c'est
succès locaux en servit un peu de leur
ou en tout cas on peut inciter ces
parties qu'on peut parler de l'air ou de
du PS à beaucoup plus travaillé pour
faire émerger de nouvelles de nouvelles
choses très rapidement il ne travaille
plus il ne réfléchissent plus ils n'ont
plus de de socle intellectuel il ne
travaille plus avec des des gens qui qui
demandent aux Français ce qu'ils pensent
vraiment au fond et ça c'est un des
problèmes de ces ancien parti merci
beaucoup à tous les trois